I'm here with a dear old friend
and the incredibly charming Scott Speedman.
(audience applauding)
Aww, Speedman, I'm so happy for you. I really am.
I love when you call me Speedman, it's great,
I love it.
I've only ever called you Speedman,
I only will ever call you Speedman,
even now that you're about to be a dad at any moment.
I'm just so happy for you and Lindsay really.
I mean, we knew each other when we were kids
and we're being grownups now.
And I don't think it ever feels like being a grownup,
but I don't know what that, what that sensation is,
but it, I'm glad we're at this time in our lives
and that everything.
For sure.
That you're just killing it out there, you know,
with your career and parenthood,
just doing all the things Speedman.
I'm trying to do all the things, trying to be an adult,
we'll see how it goes.
Well, part of doing all the things and being an adult
and being in our jobs is being on social media.
Yes.
Well, I would love to personally get involved
in a social media game.
I want to, I'm all up in your biz, Speedman,
in a segment we're calling, Drew it for the Gram.
Oh no, it sounds terrible already.
(Drew laughing)
All right, for every good social media account,
it needs a good Throwback Thursday.
So I used those two pictures that I personally took,
of you in the first segment.
Let's bring up you and Justin.
This would be a great one to do
under hashtag throwback Thursday.
Everybody loves a throwback.
Yes, TBT, I got you.
Aww, it's wonderful.
Yeah, I'm getting it. I'm getting it.
Well, the other one,
as I spoke to Martha Stewart about personally,
and she taught me all about a thirst trap.
That would be a thirst trap.
Is it? I don't think that's a thirst trap.
I don't know what that is, but not a thirst trap.
That's like a disorientated human
who's probably inebriated in the middle of a party
with his underpants.
(both laughing)
Okay. Lastly, it always helps to have a picture
with an influencer,
that will literally boost your numbers
like nobody's business.
Influencers are quite powerful people,
such as someone that we have here.
She has over 1.1 million Instagram followers.
And over 1.6 million TikTok followers,
please look at one of her most famous videos right here.
I had so many cute outfits planned for this year
that I couldn't wear.
So I just wanted to show you.
See this? I love it, I couldn't wear it.
Love it, couldn't wear it.
Then there's this. Love it, couldn't wear it.
And this was supposed to me my cute costume but no.
Please say hello to the one and the only,
the original.
She's so hot she actually has imitators.
It's Tika the Iggy.
(audience applauding)
She is a phenomenon.
Okay.
She really, really is. I mean, I'm starstruck.
I really am.
And she liked me. She, she gave me a big lick earlier,
which was really nice.
And if you would like, we'd all like to take a picture
with you Speedman and Tika,
and I'm telling you, it's gonna.
Up that, up the game? Up it?
Up that game. 'Cause Tika has game.
All right. So here we go.
We're gonna lean in. I'm gonna,
I'm gonna come closer to you.
Okay.
(audience laughing)
And then we'll look forward.
We'll say Tika on three. Ready?
One, two, three, Tika.
Tika.
(both laughing)
(audience applauding)
Great, thanks Tika. I appreciate it.
I will make sure to get a special message
and some words of wisdom from Tika to send to you.
But mostly I'm probably gonna send you some gear
that I discovered along the way of being a parent
that absolutely was essential.
And I know you Speedman, I feel like you're gonna
want to travel light and like,
I'm gonna get you some light gear.
Nimble.
Yes, exactly!
I'm gonna get you some light, nimble gear.
Okay.
Because parents can get really overloaded,
like just going to the grocery store you feel like you're,
you know, packing up a U-Haul and it's not.
(Speedman and audience laughing)
Okay. These are the things I don't know.
I don't know what I don't know.
That's the thing here. I don't know what I don't know.
Well, I think we all know this.
We love Scott Speedman.
Oh, well right back at you. Thank you.
Great to see you.
I'm so happy for you, Speedman. I really am.
Season 18 of Grey's Anatomy airs Thursday at nine,
Eight Central on ABC.
And be sure to check out the new season of You
streaming now on Netflix.
Love you Speedman, we'll be right back.
Love you. See you, bye!
(upbeat music)